the Turkish backed militia fighters have
been gathering for days for a major
offensive on the Kurdish city of
Rassilon it's the farthest move east so
far in this conflict a breach in the
Turkish border wall and it began foot
soldiers fanning out across fields
heading for the town they're backed up
by armored vehicles artillery and air
power this is an invasion there was some
resistance but in reality this force
outnumbered and outgunned
anyone left to defend the town now
deserted an hour to the south the
Kurdish militia are gathering up to head
to the front lines these men have been
pulled back from the town of d rizal
they're the first to get here they're
lightly armed but are going into battle
regardless they're shouting they will
defend Resul a
against an army supported with airpower
they're driving towards carnage but the
Kurds have nowhere to go so they're
going regardless the roads towards rasa
Lane are quiet now civilians have left
on mass as we approached a critical
turning point our phones began ringing
the town was lost we were told and all
the roads taken we had to turn back
we're getting calls coming in to our
drivers and our producers here saying
that the road ahead of us has now been
cut off by Turkish supporting militia
which is the Free Syrian Army FSA as
it's known and people are effectively
drawn quickly to the Tanith has to come
out what's important to remember is that
that means that the border area that
Turkey wants to make into our buffer
zone as they call it he's basically
being taken over by troops on the land
as opposed to just being attacked with
artillery and this is a huge development
the city of Hasek er isn't all that safe
but it's a safest place in these parts
at the moment and thousands upon
thousands of people are pouring in
people in trucks are on roadsides have
fled the fighting displaced now homeless
some are being put up in schools that
are already full and aren't suitable for
a long stay men women and children are
sharing classrooms all left everything
behind as the fighting intensified
nobody cares they say volunteers are
helping the best they can for now the
city can cope they say but for one major
problem there is no water in hosaka
anymore the pumping station has been
destroyed in the fighting
we're trying to help like we'll try to
help you try to do the best for our
people you're all together yeah all the
Kurds need to help each other in a
matter of just a few days this crisis
has dramatically escalated the Kurds are
trapped and against the second biggest
army in NATO they are to all intents and
purposes defenseless this crisis will
soon become a humanitarian disaster
do Rams of Sky News in Northeast Syria